game day got underway a person was
critically hurt in a hit-and-run
accident this happened near legion
stadium we of course have been following
this since this afternoon the driver
responsible got out of their car and ran
from the scene madison kimbrough is live
from the scene with the latest details
on this
yeah sasha you can see county crews out
here i'm going to step out of the way so
you can see they are assessing the area
where the pole was hit by the suv this
occurred right before 5 this afternoon
here on valley view and russell metro
police say one person was taken to the
hospital after a dark gold suv hit a
person crossing the street according to
witnesses that person was a man who was
on his way to the game after being hit
the driver of the suv got out of the car
and ran from the scene towards i-15 we
spoke to one onlooker who says
unfortunately she's not surprised
something like this took place on game
day
the son-in-law he comes in here and he's
crying he's like you know if we can
watch his truck or park it somewhere he
doesn't care because he has to go see
what's going on so i asked him like is
everything okay if he's going to be okay
he said he has no idea so he just gets
in his truck and i guess they're all
going
to the hospital i felt like something
like this was going to happen because
everybody is drunk and it's the start of
the new season and i just had it in my
gut like
something is going to happen
the road was blocked off for hours but
is currently open to drivers and we
currently don't have a description of
the person hit or the driver but of
course this is an ongoing investigation
and we will be sure to keep you updated
on air and online so keep it here on 8
news now reporting live madison
kimbrough 8 news now